Welcome back everyone
It's Charlie, and Bob Iger the CEO of Disney,
just made a bunch of big Marvel announcements
about the way they're completely changing
the upcoming movies and Disney Plus series,
the beginning of the great Marvel pivot
and what's essentially the very beginning
of the rebooting of the MCU,
not just the more obvious resetting of the way
it looks on screen in terms of the characters
that they're doing, the projects they're doing,
but also rebooting the way
that they make things behind the scenes.
we're talking about a bunch of changes
to what you know as Marvel.
So we'll break it all down.
If you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe to get all the videos.
The Deadpool
three trailer supposed to come in a couple of days.
Of course I will do all the videos for it.
There's a bunch of Super Bowl trailers coming.
They've even started to release
a bunch of Super Bowl trailers the past couple of days.
so try to do videos
for as much of that stuff as possible.
but just recently, Bob Iger
did this big earnings call for Disney
where he announced the entire companies financials,
how they did recently.
and he claims that he turned the company
around in a big way, helping them make way more money
last year, not just the Marvel movies and shows,
but all Disney was losing a ton of money.
It was a huge problem.
A while ago,
Disney brought Bob Iger back to turn the ship around
because under Bob Chapek,
the person that took over for Bob Iger, essentially
the company started to go down the tanks
they and a bunch of other companies started losing
just many, many billions of dollars
on their streaming pivots.
They had tried to pull off like not just
Disney Plus was losing a ton of money,
but all the other streaming networks.
it was totally chaotic.
There were a lot of reasons why everybody was losing
money, like basically pumping money
into their streaming networks,
expecting that it would deliver on subscribers.
When it did not, they started to lose crazy money.
So basically everybody's shifting back to the way
they used to release all their movies and TV shows.
The circle is now complete.
And a big problem that Disney had was
they were releasing way
too much stuff,
way too fast under Marvel, under Star Wars.
It wasn't just a marvel problem.
Star Wars had this problem to with Disney basically
trying to focus
too much on those two brands,
trying to pump out way too much stuff.
Like they asked the question under Bob Chapek rule,
Could any movie be a marvel movie?
Like, could all movies be Marvel movies in?
The answer obviously is no.
one of their big problems
was that they were almost too successful
with Avengers, Endgame
and then Spider-Man far from home right after that.
That earned over $1,000,000,000.
they basically took the year
2019 is a sign that they could do
pretty much anything
and fans would just come along for the ride, like,
we'll release anything and you'll just enjoy it
because it has the Marvel name on it.
cut to a couple of years later.
how wrong they were.
You can't just release anything
and then put the Marvel name on it like it
actually has to be good To be fair,
though, a lot of the blame
actually goes to Bob Chapek,
who basically gave Kevin Feige the edict.
This is also a star Wars problem, too.
But we're talking more about Marvel
because this is a marvel video basically forcing
Kevin Feige to release more and more Marvel
TV shows and more Marvel movies every single year.
In another big problem
is that typically they earn a lot of their money
on families going to see their movies.
It's one thing for a person to buy a movie ticket.
Like movie tickets are expensive,
but imagine a family buying four or five movie tickets.
That's way more money in Disney's pocket.
They count on that.
what happened during the pandemic?
Because they started releasing stuff on Disney
Plus and they got people used to the idea
that they would just eventually or quickly
after releasing in theaters release it on Disney
plus like, I don't have to go to theaters.
I could just wait like 30, 60 days
and watch it for free on Disney.
Plus, I'm already paying for that. Technically.
so one of the big changes, the Disney marvel basically
like all the streaming companies did,
is pivot back to more theatrical releases like,
no, no, no, we're not going to release it on streaming
four way, way longer
a big part of Disney turning the ship around
marvel all their brand Star wars just in general
bringing Bob Iger back and sort of returning things
back to a level that they were at before the pandemic,
like before this explosion of streaming networks.
what this basically translated to
Marvel was basically allowing them
to not have to release a bunch of stuff
from all their movies and TV shows every single year
in not just changing the schedule
of all their releases,
but also changing the way
that they make everything to just allowing them
more time to make more quality movies
and changing the way they make TV shows
to make them more like TV shows instead of
just trying to chop up movies into six different parts.
what Marvel is doing going forward right now
is decreasing
the overall number of Marvel movies
they released per year.
Deadpool three, for instance, is the only Marvel
MCU movie they're releasing this year.
it almost seems like next year
there's only going to be two Marvel movies
And they're releasing the number of Disney
Plus TV series they release every year
and completely refocusing the movies and shows
just in general on their core characters and brands.
The way that Bob Iger talked about it, focusing more
on their most popular, strongest characters and brands.
that essentially means they're not going to be giving
every one of their sister their own Disney
Plus series in the movies
will focus more on their more popular characters.
It begins this year with Deadpool
three Wolverine, the X-Men coming back.
But it's just the start.
This involves them changing a lot of their upcoming
movie plans in upcoming TV show plans.
Now I know a ton of you are asking
what's getting canceled, though.
Like, obviously there were like billions of shows
they had in development, billions of movies
that they had planned for.
What are they not doing anymore?
if you look back at the original Marvel
phase five Comic-Con schedule
they released, this serves as a good example.
Also the Marvel Phase six Schedule two Originally
they were going to release around five Disney
Plus TV series this year in about four Marvel movies,
and we would have seen the transition from Marvel phase
five to Marvel phase six with things getting way
more cosmic heading into Avengers five, Avengers six,
which were supposed to start next year and happen
in the same year, like two Avengers movies next year
back to back.
that's a crazy high output.
and you look at these schedules,
you can see a lot of their titles feature either
brand new characters
or totally new teams that they were going to introduce.
basically we were still kind of
in this era of Marvel post Avengers Endgame,
where they were just throwing a bunch of ideas
at the wall with new characters, new teams,
seeing what works before they decide
who's going to be on that next Avengers team.
Well, they stalled for a time, waiting for the upcoming
new X-Men and Fantastic Four movies to start
because notice there's no X-Men on the schedules
here yet, even though Kevin Feige has since announced
that they're making a new X-Men movie Deadpool
three got added after they released these,
and that was the beginning of their X-Men
mutant focused stuff, which now seems like
the characters that they're going to be pivoting to
for the next ten years of Marvel
confirming a lot of our theories, mostly
because there's a treasure chest
of A-list characters in those X-Men movies
that for them is an untapped goldmine.
Deadpool three is just the beginning
the a couple of the really good examples of stuff
they're not doing going forward anymore are shows
like She-Hulk and Echo for very different reasons.
The primary reason they're not going to be doing
any more series like She-Hulk is the money.
It always comes down to money.
People will make lots of excuses like,
I hated this character.
Hey, the way they did these jokes,
some of this other stuff over here.
But really it just comes down to money because Marvel,
like all companies, only care about making more money,
She-Hulk, for instance, cost them over $225 million,
which is a lot more than some of their biggest movies
originally.
Kevin Feige said they didn't
want to spend more than $150 million on each TV series.
so unless
like everybody on the planet subscribes to Disney plus
and then stays subscribed after these TV series
they're basically losing
hundreds of millions of dollars
every time they release something like She-Hulk
this also gets back to Marvel's quantity over
quality problem under the Bob Chapek era of rule
a lot of the movies
and the TV shows that are being released right now
were actually greenlit in went into production
under the Bob Chapek era of rule
where he was basically forcing Kevin Feige
to release a bunch of TV shows and movies.
and one of the bigger problems
behind the scenes that they ran into
is that Kevin Feige just did not have enough time
to do the quality control that he would normally do
on Marvel movies and TV series.
When they started releasing that stuff,
he started delegating to his lieutenants
and apparently, like probably the worst of
it was actually during the secret invasion series.
There's a book that somebody could write
about all the problems
behind the scenes with the making of Secret Invasion.
so now Marvel is just releasing
fewer overall series and movies per year,
not only giving them more time to make the series,
make them well fix any issues that might come up.
It also allows them to only focus on the stronger,
more popular or likely to become popular characters.
they're not doing as many special presentations like
they're not making movies for Disney Plus specifically.
in instead of trying
to give a bunch of different characters their own
limited six episode event series,
they're focusing more on longer episode runs
and multiple seasons of shows,
starting with Daredevil Born Again, Essentially,
they're trying to make TV shows more like actual
TV shows that you would expect on normal television.
We watched Daredevil Born Again Season one,
then we get Daredevil,
born again season two, and they just continue forward.
this is why
previously you haven't seen that many Marvel TV series
get season two's in when they did give stuff
season two like Loki Season two.
It wasn't till after they made Season
one that they decided to make a season two
but one of the other big problems that Marvel has
is this backlog
of TV shows and movies
that went into development or already got made in
are sitting on a shelf right now
waiting to be released for the next couple of years,
which is why a lot of fans, for instance,
will not see the actual full extent
of the changes that they just made, the good changes
for a couple of years,
what you'll notice for the next year
or two is just fewer overall movies and series.
But largely like all the stuff coming out the next
few years was stuff that was greenlit a long time ago.
And also big surprise, Avengers five
is still listed as King Dynasty in May 2026.
Look, they haven't changed the title officially yet.
That kind of implies
that they're still going to use the Council of Kings
and just recast the character
or multiple versions of King.
If they make announcements about that.
I will do new videos.
but essentially, Bob Iger
just confirmed a lot of my theories
from last year after the rumors
about all of these changes started happening.
Marvel doing a soft reboot on the MCU
just in general, using the opportunity
to fix any issues
they had with characters recast anybody they needed to.
After Secret Wars
pivot to a more X-Men mutant focused Marvel phase.
I mean, like the Mutant Saga
generally refocusing on quality
over quantity and their strongest characters and teams.
a lot of people will credit Deadpool
three this year with turning the ship
around, like getting lapsed fans interested in Marvel's
future again.
In reality.
Kevin Feige the people at Marvel
who are actually making all this stuff
started to make these changes way earlier last year.
It's just that the movies
take a few years to make TV shows too,
so you're not really seeing it on screen
for a couple of years.
everybody post all your reactions in your predictions
in the comments below.
Big reminder to lot of Deadpool
3 stuff coming in the next couple of days,
so be sure to enable alerts for my channel
so you don't miss any of that stuff.
A bunch of big Super Bowl trailers from other stuff
coming to Click here for my new Deadpool
three video and click here
to learn about Marvel bringing Thanos back
Thank you so much for watching
and I'll see you guys in the next one!